ça tourne un peu au cauchemar on a
l'impression parfois d'être dans un
mauvais film l'américain de série b
voilà quand est-ce que ça va se terminer
avec un scénario qui semble se répéter
indéfiniment
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on cherche depuis deux ans
la stratégie sanitaire 1 dans cette
affaire dudu coronavirus 1 on voit
simplement des mesures qui se succèdent
qui s'empilent plus ou moins cohérentes
d'ailleurs plutôt incohérente voilà et
tout ceci ne ne dessinent pas une
perspective optimiste
[Musique]
à quoi sert-il de nous communiquer le
nombre de cas sachant que le nombre de
cas n'équivaut pas au nombre de malades
donc il ya effectivement une irritation
de l'affolement 1 quand effectivement on
répète à longueur de temps les mêmes
choses qu'on revient sur les mêmes
mesures qu'on assiste à ce ballet
interminable de médecins qui pour
beaucoup d'ailleurs n'exprime même pas
de position scientifique mais simplement
une opinion l'opinion l'opinion du
moment voilà il ya un sentiment de 2,2
ras-le-bol
[Musique]